something you want to tell me about yes
I would like to talk to you about a
equation that is called fits law and how
that affects the way that you point at
things and use a cursor on your computer
fits like Fitz's or fit soft it Fitz's
but that sounds funny so I'm just going
to say fits but know that I know that
there are two S's in there okay it
belongs to Paul Fitz who is a researcher
in 1954 he was trying to work out how we
could predict the speed of people's
movements from one location to another
and what he was doing he was trying to
work this out
from a kind of perspective of how we can
make production lines more efficient
where people are putting pieces together
but what he didn't realize then at the
time was that it really really is useful
when talking about how people move
things on our computer screen how people
move a mouse cursor on a computer screen
and the result of this formula means
that we can predict how quickly you can
move between one target and another and
depending on a few variables what are we
talking about here a target is anything
you might want to click on on the
computer screen so you want to go to a
menu item you want to close a window you
want to highlight some text any
situation in where you're moving your
cursor to another location on screen
that's what I'm calling a target here
I'll write down the formula for you and
then we can talk about which elements of
it matter and which things you can
choose to change as a designer and how
you can use this formula to optimize the
layout the user interface of something
on a computer screen so the equation is
the time it takes you to move from your
location to a target is equal to a plus
B times log base two of amplitude over
width plus one the variables within this
equation we have a and B here we can
kind of ignore those so a and B just
mean that you can adapt this equation
depending or
what people are actually using to do the
pointing so if for example they were
using a stylus you might need to make it
take a bit longer than if they were
using a mouse or something like that so
a and B are kind of used for that it is
like little dials and tweak exactly yeah
yeah that's exactly what they do so we
can kind of ignore those what we're
interested in here are the variables a
and W amplitude and width and these
things describe the target
so the amplitude describes how far away
the target is from your start position
and the width describes the width of the
target unsurprisingly how big the target
is exactly it's having a landing pad
you've got exactly so the width gives
you an idea about exactly how accurate
you need to be when you get to that
target the wider something is the less
accurate you need to be and the way that
we use this formula is that we want to
minimize the amount of time that someone
takes and so we want to minimize this
term and to do that we can do two things
as designers firstly we can make this
value that a amplitude small which means
we can make the target closer or we can
make W the width large so we can make
the target massive this seems pretty
obvious it does seem obvious that she
reminds me of sport as well like
anything in sport like darts you either
have a big bullseye or you stand closer
to them yeah well it is quite obvious
but the interesting thing is that we
have an actual equation to describe it
it's not just something that we can
intuitively work out it's something that
has been tested really really thoroughly
to get to get some equations out of it
the way that fits tested it is he got
people to hold a stylus and then move
quickly back and forth between two
targets and he altered the distance of
those targets away from each other and
the width of those targets and he came
out with this wonderful formula to to
actually accurately describe it now
let's actually think about what this
means for design and actually what we
can do with this formula in order to
make really useful
interfaces and really quick to use
interfaces so thinking about amplitude
the way that we can minimize this that
is the distance we want to minimize it
is to give people things exactly at
their cursor point so the closest pixel
to you is the one where your cursor is
and so that's why you get quite a lot of
useful functionality at the cursor point
that is you right-click you don't need
to make any movement whatsoever
and so that is a target that's really
really easy to get to this is the menu
that pops up next to the thing exactly
like a tooltip menu and that means that
you can put all of the very useful
functionality right there because it's
incredibly easy for the user to get to
wherever you happen to be you
right-click and exactly exactly where
ever you are is exactly where that menu
is so that's one way of doing it that's
I don't think that's that interesting
now if we think about with this is the
really interesting part to me where do
you think the best places to click on it
on a screen what's that what's the
easiest place to get to on a screen the
edges I guess because you can't miss the
edge that's exactly it I say so if you
put a target in the corners of the
screen what you have essentially done
there is created a target that is
infinitely wide right you've you've made
it so that no matter how far up and how
far right they go the user will always
be on that target and that's why the
corners are such useful areas on a
computer screen because they are
infinitely wide which makes this
equation get a lot smaller and so it
means you can get to those corner areas
really really quickly it's interesting
because I think some people were upset
with Apple because the X at the top
right on some interfaces that really is
wedged right into the top and so
therefore it is infinitely big but then
I think Apple brought it down and made
it into a circle so they move the target
from being infinitely massive to a tiny
little circle just by bringing in like a
couple of pixels from the edge which is
kind of silly of them but it's
interesting that you can do that it's
the Fitz equation do you imagine this is
something but in the halls of Microsoft
and Apple and game designers
that they're always thinking about or is
this something that academics like you
look at afterwards and smugly say well
they should have done this or the real
reason they did it is because of this or
do you think they apply this equation
now I I do genuinely believe this is
something that's that people are very
much considering when they're designing
things there are loads of different
variations of it so for obviously now
we're starting to move to like
touchscreens and so things get a bit get
a bit more different because the corners
of your iPad are definitely not the best
place to put things because there's no
such thing as this infinite width and
height and so the equations are having
to change and alter depending on the new
technology that is coming out but it is
definitely still being it's definitely
still being used by people in order to
justify and come up with clever ideas
for interfaces
we like to thank audible.com for this
episode of computerphile and if you're
not aware of audible do check them out
they've got audiobooks online I've got
thousands to choose from and if you go
to audible.com slash computerphile
there's a chance to download one for
free
now today I'd like to recommend this
book about Elon Musk he's one of the
cofounders of Google and it's called
Tesla SpaceX and the quest for the
fantastic future I think I've got that
right hopefully I'll be here on the
screen by now so he's billed as a
real-life Tony Stark you know the guy
behind Ironman so get over to
audible.com slash computer file download
your free book and thanks once again to
them for sponsoring this computer file
video
they're not testing the actual machines
yet what they're doing in this paper is
giving people a booklet that just has
this on it when people fill this in 55
percent of people chose the phone layout
55 percent of people went well obviously
it should go like this